well let's put it this way when I'm
driving really awake and Hannah's
driving I'm super awake I grew up in a
lot of countries where you don't need to
know how to drive coming back to North
American culture and seeing everybody
have like the independence of driving
around in a car I was like so jealous
and my dad went out and got a brand new
Toyota Corolla he described it as
champagne gold parallel parking seemed
crazy like it just seemed crazy that you
would like back up and then inch for it
so I one of my dad to teach me that
lasted about five minutes I always
believed in you know raising kids with
love and compassion and that day I lost
it all when I get my car my seat is back
and I'm sitting like this hi nice to see
I look like a little old lady in tents
oh my god
that's the car
ah I do miss it yes does it what do you
guys say that we actually go see if she
can really parallel park I hear a
problem there's people here is the way
here
don't turn now okay now we hit a cone
all right that's perfect right there
that's good parallel parking so did it
finish
[Music]